oh that's very nice
thanks for being here thank you i love
the the new home digs well they're not
so new now but i know but no it's nice
it's got a uh it still feels new to us
we've been here over a year now it's
actually i don't know why we're having a
year anniversary special because it's
been like a year and three months or
something i don't know i'm making that
up but uh i like it and you can check
out the surf the wonderful surf there's
a breeze that comes in i like it it's
good stuff got a lot of nice fake plants
a grossly inaccurate moon
uh i meant to congratulate you when you
first uh came out here because uh parks
and recreation one of the funniest shows
on television you guys are doing a great
job so you must be thrilled about that
you're having a good time
thank you
i am um
i love it everybody's funny and fun and
it almost feels like you're not working
and i really think at the end of the day
they just want to try to figure out how
they can humiliate me on a daily basis
it doesn't no just as a casual as as a
viewer i
i do notice that it almost seems like
they're sitting around thinking what can
we get rob lowe to do
when will he say no i
i've done horrific air banjo playing
i i just this week sang the worst
version of take me out to the ball game
right anyone's ever seen and of course
i've done some serious white man dancing
yeah yeah
and that was they didn't even ask you to
do that that was just you trying to be
good yeah
the the uh and then you did something
that went viral uh i remember what it
was but it was uh it was like it was
this very humiliating moment where they
just and it suddenly was everywhere on
the computer yeah it was me looking in
the mirror at myself and telling myself
to stop pooping yeah yeah because you
know i need to be reminded of that on a
daily basis other people look in the
mirror and say you can do it or go get
em that's your mantra every day it works
for me conan all right i'm happy for you